all right this is the list you guys have
been waiting for these are the top ten
cliches that drive me crazy now I notice
a lot of cliches that people like I like
to and we like seeing them over and over
these are the ones that I personally
can't stand seeing a lot of people do
list above cliches and not saying these
are the worst cliches these are just the
ones that I hate that I personally
despise I feel they ruin a movie a lot
of these films would be fine if they
didn't have these in here
I'll have them keep using all these
cliches in one so why waste any time
let's talk about the top ten cliches
that I hate number ten calling women
girls we've seen this in Blues Brothers
Ghostbusters Red Sonja Superman 2 to me
girl is like birth to high
school/college maybe you know a lot of
them look a lot younger than I can
understand when you're one you're you're
a woman okay when you got Tatas nice big
top tides you are a woman if you're
gonna go out there you're gonna save the
day you're gonna be strong and you know
all this stuff you're not a girl anymore
okay you're a woman now I know the idea
that a lot of people like to think you
know oh girl is younger and you know it
fuck that shape you're gonna be a main
character if you're gonna be you know
going out there doing it with the guys
and stuff like that you're a woman okay
girls you know I think of like I said
high score playing on playgrounds or
something like that and for me it's hard
for me to take a character seriously
when they keep calling what is obviously
a grown woman a girl actually the
biggest cases for me I think of are in
space mutiny where they actually make
fun of that because the woman is like I
don't know wonder Easy's or something
like that they keep calling your girl
and I think in plan 9 from outer space
these are both Mystery Science Theater
z-- uh they keep calling this character
girl and it's so obvious she's in like
her 40s or 50s so I guess that's more of
a pet peeve that's a pet peeve ever only
bothers me the other cliches are
probably gonna be a lot more obvious so
uh but yeah that one always
number nine the shaky-cam
we've seen this in transformers in
Batman Begins in Batman Forever and God
knows how many Jerry Bruckheimer
productions what's the point now here's
a vape you want to look realistic a
little shaking is okay when somebody's
running the camera shakes a little bit
but nobody runs like loose because
that's what you see half the time you
just see a person I mean the person must
be going through a seizure when the
running or filming this I mean this is I
think I'm like in the rock there's a
scene where like Sean Connery is just
talking uh in the car and literally the
camera is zooming in and out or what the
hell's that new one um it's the Denzel
Washington train movie I cannot forget
unstoppable unstoppable every shot in
this movie zooms in zooms out zooms in
zooms out I it was on a plane when I was
flying once and the sound wasn't even on
and it was annoying the shit out of me
this camera would not stand the fuck
still it's gonna zoom in zoom out zoom
in zoom out and hey if you really just
want to see an experiment that doesn't
work see that move because all it is is
zooming in and out I mean it's what
person does the how's that make you more
realistic do you ever have a
conversation with someone just going no
you don't it's crazy so I think a lot of
people hate the shaky cam I think we're
sick of it we like to see the action and
anyone can do this
so please please people out there a
little bit is okay make it realistic but
just keep it still man keep it still
number eight
suckee credit again we seen this in
Batman Forever we seen it in liar liar
we've seen it in mrs. Doubtfire we see
it in movies that just don't care how
they start they're just like oh no we
don't get there just credits roll it and
that pisses me off because that's the
perfect moment to suck people in
give them ideal account world you're
gonna see you know play some music let
the musicians really spend their you
know their talents really try to get
people in this movie and they just
started I mean it and show nothing it's
like people are talking there's just
little credits flashing at the bottom
it's it's like a TV show a TV show I
understand you have to get the show
going you ain't have a certain amount of
time with movies it's a movie and people
used to get really creative with credits
they would have these big opening
productions they have animations they'd
have all sorts of little atmospheric
things that they would do now which I
don't mind they're starting to do it at
the end of movies like with 300 they did
that I think some of the mommy movies
are doing that it was a terrible movies
by the way but I guess um
so more people are doing sort of these
big collages and stuff at the end which
technically is more clever because
you're looking back at the good scenes
from the movie while the credits are
rolling so that's kind of clever
um but I like them at the beginning like
I think of Ben Dobbs and Broomsticks and
you know the the drawings and the music
yeah that just that gets you hyped up
for the movie so credits are a great
chance for people to get hyped up really
excited and if you don't take advantage
of it
man you're a fool number seven
relying too much on CGI and we all know
the two people have been doing way too
much of this Lucas and Spielberg they
have been relying way too much on CGI
now CGI can be used very well uh my
thought is that it's very good at making
things disappear or creating worlds or
creating atmosphere good examples a Sin
City that uh that last film version of
Peter Pan or um actually even some of
the backgrounds in the new Star Wars
movies look very nice but when you have
to get close-ups when you have to see
people there uh use actual people use
actual things get the puppets back get
the animatronics I know it's cheaper but
we know it's not there sometimes you
can't help it
transformers I get you have to use the
CGI understand that but for things like
Indiana Jones what's the best thing in
the last Indiana Jones movies one day we
were having the chase with the
motorcycle why cuz it was actually
happening it was really there um another
example that just the Robert Zemeckis
thing like this is all he's doing now is
making these CGI movies and at first I
was kind of intrigued I was really sort
of blown away by the technology but by
the time we got to Mars Needs Moms which
thank God bombed and I think closed down
that production uh sorry people lost
their jobs but I am II just for the sake
of art uh that was done that was it
because here's the thing they try so
hard to get people to look realistic you
know Jim Carrey A Christmas Carol yeah
you can make his nose long yeah it sort
of looks like he's really there here's a
crazy idea why not really put him there
why not just have an actor there if
you're gonna go animation do animation
you know make it so that the eyes can
get big or you know so it's drunk and go
uh you know or whatever let the animator
express himself let animators do what
animators are supposed to do with this
you're restricted I saw this really the
previous with Mars news magic and all
these weird visuals going on and these
dull human faces on the CG puppet bodies
and that's what they look like they
don't look like they look like puppets
and animation is not supposed to do that
it's supposed to make something look
alive and oddly enough having a person
in there we put little dots on is too
much
so bottom line I'm not against CGI all
of it if you look at some older effects
for like ghostbusters and stuffs of them
look great some of them are really dated
and some CG would have helped that but
yeah we rely way too much on and we we
got a bag down man we get we had to like
the Lord of the Rings path where they
sort of did half and half so um yeah I
think we really let's get some flesh and
blood back in there number six
over using the wide-angle lens you saw
me just talk about this in baby geniuses
Danny DeVito does it a lot in his movies
whenever a movie obviously just has no
cinematic creativity they just go to the
super-tight wide-angle shot and when
they first start doing it it was
interesting we hadn't seen wide-angle
shots that much but by the 20-time we
had to see somebody like this it gets
really annoying and you just want to
push the screen away from you I don't
know why people rely on so much I guess
it's because they want to look different
they want to look artsy they want to
look like hey we're doing something
nobody else is doing but everybody else
is doing it so finally people are
starting to back down a bit but there
are still some directors out there that
still think they're being really
innovative and avant-garde by doing this
it's not it's tiring it's boring I'm
sick of it
wide angle is a wonderful device to use
just stop putting it this close to a
person's nose number five
the poetic singer this is another one
I've gone on and on about you've seen it
in Avatar you've seen it in district
nine you've seen it in Black Hawk Down
you've seen it in gladiator it's when a
big dramatic scene happens where
somebody dies or somebody's remembering
something poetic and you hear that
singer that singer that goes oh and oh
ear poison it is ear poison I can't
stand it and every time I hear it I want
to strangle the lady or man who it's
singing and it's so obnoxious I mmm I'm
talking about this one so much I don't
even want to talk about that much I just
know whenever there's a pretentious wave
you want a movie to be pretentious it's
just like boom pretentious there's no
turning back you get that singer you get
that son of a daughter of bitch person
because that person is a pain I'm sure
he or she is making great money or it's
a couple people doing it I don't know
but shut that person up stop using him
her in number four the whimsical
innocent rebellious poet at least half
of Robin Williams movies are this the
meek kind of quirky person who has a
heart of gold but screws up sometimes
but gosh darn it he's trying this has
probably come from the 90s Disney films
with like Ariel and Belle and Ladin and
all these characters that dream of more
and want so much more but they're just
so quirky uh and in Disney films
actually they work okay but even that's
getting really overused in romantic
comedies there's always the woman Julia
Roberts movies where yeah she screws up
sometimes she does the wrong thing but
you know what gosh darn it she cares and
the person going up against the man the
big establishment the rebel you know and
the the big bad people who put him down
just because he wanted to dream and we
don't understand and you see this with a
lot of movies of
you know people with special needs and
stuff which you know I'm not saying you
know that they don't need special needs
I'm not saying that it's that this has
just been done so many times and it
hasn't been done in a new way or a way
that really makes you care it's a way
we've seen up in Chile and other times
and I'm just sick of the stuffy and a
person who just wears the finger and
says you don't get em you don't
understand and the young rebel says yes
I do and I'm gonna show you when they go
all determined and yeah they make some
mistakes but they come through and we're
on their side fucking hate those people
fucking eat those movies fucking hate
that cliche fucking hate it I'm very
angry in this video number three the
misunderstanding again a lot of romances
use this you get this in Shrek you get
this in the wedding singer you get it in
40 days 40 nights
it's that scene where that couple you
know that's been fighting throughout the
entire movie trying to prove to you that
no they're not gonna fall in love and
then there's that cheese maybe they will
and then the misunderstanding that has
them go to their corners think they hate
each other and they just mope they do
nothing but mope and it's so boring we
see that so many times again and they
play the pop song they play the guitar
song and you just want to turn it's not
coach am very fond of because it's
supposed to be that the area where it
creates drama this is the drama now and
what's gonna happen you know what's
gonna happen we know exactly what's
gonna happen one's gonna realize they
were an idiot or they're both idiots
Moulin Rouge was guilty of this too um
and at some point they're going to take
a chance and even though logically it
makes no sense they're going to go to
that person they love and they're gonna
confess their love but wait time's
running out oh we better hurry if only
that misunderstanding didn't happen
we don't need those misunderstandings
just show a couple and love just show
real problems that happen you know I I
think that's
bothers me about these cliches is that
if they happened more in real life maybe
they would work but they don't they're
so contrived and this is one that always
gets to me and just every time happens
it just it just holds the movie it just
stops it and you sort of get that avatar
also with they're trying to tell them
that you know the big bag humans are
coming oh really aren't you the big bed
humans well and they don't listen that's
the other thing it falls under there
they don't listen it's one side not
listening to the other and just before I
know what we're doing go in there so
it's sort of a mix between the
misunderstanding and the not listening
that really gets to me it's so tired I'm
so tired
number two the liar revealed this is
also everywhere you see it in a bug's
life you see it in Rango you see it in
wedding crashers it's when a character
lies about who he or she really is which
that's not bad because that creates
comedy or that creates something
interesting someone who's acting like
something they're usually not that's
fine I have no problem that because you
can get very creative with that it's
when the people find out who the person
really is chicken run did this too it's
a big thing in kids films I realize um
that they find out who the person really
is and because of that they don't trust
him they're just like Oh get it out of
here we don't need you anymore and the
person feels bad and walks away sad
again kills the movie for like 10 20
minutes it just stops and you just get
moping I'm sick of moping when it's not
needed if it's for a good reason that's
great but when it's not it's so
obnoxious um and they usually go in
again they realize something wait a
minute I may not really be this but in a
way I am I'm going back there to save
the day and they usually have to
convince the person of something you
know which usually takes a while so that
really gets me cuz again and I hate a
lot movie starts off that waive the
character lying and everybody believes
because you know it's gonna leave
to that and even though some of the
stuff going on may be funny you're just
constantly going in just get to that
scene already because I don't want to go
through a I just want get over with as
fast as possible so now there's two
movies that did variations on that they
were very very good
one was King's Speech which I don't want
to give too much away but the character
fought one character find out something
about the other character and you think
okay now they're gonna leave each other
now they're gonna do whatever and they
just realize who gives a shit and they
keep going that was great that was and
that was a great testament to you know
the film and the friendship and all that
stuff more that please that was
wonderful
um and then in our scene that is some
very similar was in Wolfinger uh but
there's a scene where Heather Graham
which Steve Martin slept with sleeps
with Eddie Murphy calls her Sciences you
we can't be going out anymore she says
why says you slept with in our man she
said so says I never thought of that
and they stay together hilarious that's
great writing just way too you know say
hey you know this thing that we give you
every single fucking movie when I go do
that we're gonna turn into a big joke
and yeah it makes the character look a
little selfish but he was selfish out
already
so that's great I love it when people
take these stupid cliches and they do
something different with it um so yet
that like I said well movie starts with
that I get so annoyed because I know
what's coming I know it's gonna drag so
please stop that get new stories it can
be about a liar just stop having that
moment where it kills the movie for that
couple of minutes
and the number one cliche that drives me
totally insane is the bully God where do
I start with this it let me in wedding
crashers every Adam Sandler movie these
are the bullies that are not interesting
they're not fun they're not developed
they're not funny if they're just there
as a tool they're just a tool to get the
plot going in the direction to you know
fill all the other cliches that we just
talked about these are literally the
guys that make pretty much every other
cliche I just talked about happen uh I
get I wouldn't mind they made them funny
a good example is in happy gilmore that
bad guy was funny there's a scene where
he's like are you pieces of shit like
you for breakfast and he's like you
pieces of shit for breakfast no is
that's funny if you make him stupid
that's funny if you make them almost
aware of it like actually Jack Black and
some of these movies as well like never
ending story three and airborne he's
actually kind of funny because he knows
he's a stereotype he knows he's a
character he has fun with it Nelson
that's a great bully again he's aware
that he's this stereotype and they poke
fun with it they make it they he's
having fun these bad guys never look
like they're having fun they never look
like they're interesting you don't want
to know about them they're just a plot
device and and they don't say funny
things they don't do interesting things
they're not complex villains are very
interesting characters you know like the
Disney Villains yeah a lot of them don't
have much motivation but they're so
charming and they're so delicious and
they're enjoying what they're doing the
main villain from inglorious basterds
not Hitler the other guy you know the
guy who you know is always smiling and
always so happy now was he evil but he
was having so much fun Alex from a
Clockwork Orange one of the worst people
on the earth and he's our hero and we
sympathize with him because he's just so
damn fascinating he has this lust for
life so you know again I don't mind
villains in movies just do them well
don't make them just bullies don't make
them these cardboard
that are just there to be jerks they
have no back story this is this is the
element I see ruining a lot of movies so
much is just the bully because all the
are cliches spawned from that and like I
was just watching their day I was
watching Kiki's Delivery Service as
Miyazaki films an awesome film you know
what happened to that movie at which
goes to a town and she just lives her
life you know what that's pretty fucking
interesting you didn't need a bully you
didn't need a misunderstanding you
didn't need you know that this kooky
romance allure what sort of romance but
it worked
cuz they were kids that's how kids
really act and oh I think if there's
anything I'm trying to get across with
this video to none of the filmmakers who
are watching this but just just film in
general is that you don't always need to
rely on these story cliches it's
something just let a movie play out just
show us a life you know show us
something that somebody has to do show
uh what the hell is that movie everybody
hated I thought was kind of good Marley
& Me I know it sounds stupid but I like
that movie because hey here's a couple
they get a dog and here's their life you
know what that's interesting it was a
big hit because they didn't need all
those other stupid freaking cliches you
know it's just here's a life it was a
life I'm sorry
so well I really rant in a lot of sorry
I guess I really wanted to get these
cliches out a lot of people don't seem
to see these cliches as much or they
don't point them out they point out more
obvious one so um hopefully these
cliches will just get less and less as
more people wake up and they stop seeing
films that are having these cliches uh
sometimes you can work around why I say
I like wedding crashers despite those
horrible cliches and there's other
movies I like they're just so tiring to
me and I'm just so done with them I
don't know if you feel the same um maybe
you can list some other cliches that
just drive you nuts ones that people
don't seem to notice for some reason
because there's obviously a lot out
there these are just the ones that
really get under my skin so uh guys I
hope you enjoy my ranting I know a lot
of people really like to
what I hate in a movie probably more
than what I like so I hope you have a
lot of fun um who I'm gonna take a big
great big breath because I'm running out
of air because I was getting so angry
there so um yeah guys thanks so much see
you around